people in the fire zone outside Los
Angeles are doing whatever they can to
support each other
CBS News found a group of people helping
collect supplies like water and gasoline
for others who lost everything they
owned in the deadly Wilson fire some of
the volunteers have learned that their
own homes had burned to the ground
Jamie yuccas is in Malibu with the
latest just heartbreaking to hear these
stories Jamie good morning good morning
it's been really tough as you can see
this tight-knit community was hit so
hard but now we're hearing stories of
neighbor helping neighbor and it's not
just compassionate it's critical as
firefighters continue to battle this
fire with the Sun setting in Malibu
former Marine Robert spangle is perched
atop Point Dume solid copy from Robert
using binoculars and a crude map drawn
by hand can you take a look across PCH
up to Ramirez and see if there's
anything burning there spangle is
spending his days and nights searching
for hot spots down below so he can radio
in to a team known as the Point Dume
crew that is helping battle the
dangerous Woolsey fire we're definitely
able to save some properties from going
up there's three or four that these guys
got to that would definitely be gone the
crew is one of several in the area
volunteering to help emergency services
teams down along the coast much of
Paradise Cove is largely untouched
thanks to people like Tim Morris whose
family owns parts of the cove using fire
hoses he joined other employees and
residents to fight back the flames I'm
very proud to say that with our
volunteers and group we didn't lose a
single trailer at Paradise Cove
you became firefighters yeah we well you
know there was no help
you know everyone everything was spread
so thin and with Malibu roads cut off
people there are bringing in supplies by
boat including water blankets diapers
gasoline and even some ice-cold beer you
just feel this need to want to help and
that's where my motivation is you know
the most important thing in the world
George Hoffman is one of those good
Samaritans helping shuttle and supplies
even after his and his sons homes were
destroyed it's a freaking amazing this
is a joyous part of the whole disaster
that we just went through that people
are coming together yeah one of the
toughest items for people to lose in a
fire like this is medication the Point
Dume crew says they're helping there too
there was a woman who's diabetic that
hadn't had insulin in two days they were
able to pick her up take her to a
neighbor's house to be treated and she's
expected to be okay bianna I mean to
find joy in this devastation by just
helping other people and trying to do
all that you can really says a lot about
this community working together yeah I
love that line you feel the need to want
to help yeah yeah we are thinking about
those volunteers and thanking them and
you can find a way a list of ways to
help the people affected by the
California wildfires just go to our
website at CBS news.com